I went into this interview expecting to
write a profile of an interesting
company that was solving a meaningful
problem and those on the path to
becoming a next billion-dollar startup
and it wasn't until after the interview
and when everything unraveled that I
realized the story of be writing would
be very different
so I met Shannon's Binaca because her
company applied to be one of our next
billion dollar startups this is a list
that Forbes has put together for the
last five years we just released our
sixth year Clio jumped out to me from
the list of our finalists for next
billion dollar startups because I was
really interested in what Clio is doing
as a company I'm an age where a lot of
my friends are having kids and they're
starting to face these questions of how
will I return to work after being a
parent when I first met Shannon I
thought she was great she's very
charismatic so when I asked her about
her age in the interview she responded
and said oh I'm 35 and then pause said
no wait I'm 36 I just turned 36 in April
and we both laughed about it because
it's a totally normal thing to forget
that oh my birthday just happened or be
off by a couple months it was when I
asked about her parents she asked oh do
I have to tell you what they do it
caught me off guard a little bit that's
kind of a question a lot of people would
answer especially if you're in the
parenting space I emailed our researcher
at Forbes and I said hi Sue I just met a
really interesting CEO her name's
Shannon sanaka she's 36 years old she
was born in April she grew up in upstate
New York can you help me find any
information about her parents and the
first thing she said it was age check
she's not 36 she's 42 we looked at voter
records of two states California and New
York and they both had the same birthday
which put her at 42 years old and then
we also checked other things like
property records that showed that she
lived in different places and the dates
matched up with her being 42 I went into
my editors office and said I think we
have a problem here and immediately our
marching orders became let's figure out
what else she has lied about in her past
there were varying things that she said
that were either straight-up lies or
stretching the truth one was an award
called the top 100 women innovate
Science and Technology from the Grace
Hopper foundation that award when you
google it it only shows up in Shannon's
search results and there is no such
thing as the Grace Hopper Foundation
calling herself a you an expert for two
years was another stretch of the truth
she had gone on to un missions to
Kazakhstan in 2015 or she was presenting
as part of a workshop but most people
who have gone to present at a UN
workshop don't consider themselves a UN
expert for two years I got on the phone
I made sure that we were on the record
with the PR person and then I simply
told her that her age didn't pass back
Chuck and it was silence
I said Shannon are you still there more
silence so eventually the PR person
jumped it on the phone and said that
they talked to me about it at a later
point and Shannon the only thing that
she said to me eventually on the phone
was that it was complicated that night
she emailed me and apologized for not
being honest with me
and I found that she'd also told her
company that day that she had lied to me
as a reporter and so I thought it was
brave with her to stand up in front of
her company and do that and the next
morning though I still had to email her
and say thanks for getting back to me
but I hope you can understand that I'll
be continuing my reporting into your
company after I talked to her about her
age she actually went back and updated
her LinkedIn and she'd removed things
like the London School of Economics at
first and removed other jobs that she
previously held from her list of
LinkedIn titles obviously somebody
updating their LinkedIn isn't any
service smoking gun but to me that was
just another sign that maybe she was
trying to change the narrative of her
past I also start reaching out to
employees both current and former on
LinkedIn and through social media the
major themes that came out of these
conversations with the employees is that
the company was selling this idea of a
better workplace for parents but
internally it was not living up to that
standard and that was something that
across-the-board employees current and
former were frustrated and I think
that's what tips the scale at the end of
the day into why this is even a story in
the first place
[Music]
I think the most part people understand
that lying about anything is bad even if
we are in this post truth post facts era
[Music]